they're American made I mean is not are
they now I'm a naturalized American I
moved here when I was like 16 I feel
like I missed out a little bit on the
part where you're supposed to get into
Twinkie as a kid my mom never let me eat
Twinkies she thinks Twinkies are the
devil you hear the word Twinkie all the
time growing up but I've never known
anyone to eat it what if we really like
it let's do it all right bring on the
Twinkies caught it first of all this
logo is delightful well it's getting oil
on my hand you can click your face with
this and shinies [ __ ] like green kind of
squirt it in my mouth when I bit it but
I'm not mad at that and it was kind of
it was kind of refreshing
this is better than I thought oh my god
like 5,000 loose if I grew up eating
this I'd be addicted hello no one what's
the push-ups count on this I don't know
but it makes me want to do a lot it's
really good though the cream is actually
good mmm I don't think I'll ever eat one
again would I eat more than one of these
yes would it give me a stomach ache
after I just want cheese so we're gonna
test the durability of this Twinkie
oh it's coming back
[Music]